we haven't really been able to talk
about it but it was cool to sing nine to
five and we did the kind of reimagined
version of nine to five for your
documentary still working nine to five
which is amazing um
not just the song but the documentary is
amazing so thank you for letting me be a
part of that i got to brag to blake
shelton about that moment
well you did a great job on that too i
love how you took that and just made it
your own and i got a chance to sing
background for a change but i'm really
proud of that rendition of it and i
think hopefully it'll do well for us
it's great in the documentary oh my god
it's a really cool thing
james do you have a favorite dolly song
yeah well first of all off of the new
album run rose run i love big dreams and
faded jeans and and warming up and take
it like a man right i love that one i
love it yeah
my life would suck without you i love
that one yeah
cheers kelly
yeah james patterson knows my music
oh my god it's amazing
[Music]
you